Comey's testifying right now, we'd be remiss
not to ask you about it.
Tie it, even, back to your work on civil libertarian
stuff.
How does this scandal, his testimony,
effect the climate for dealing with surveillance
issues and things like that from your...
I don't know how much effect it's going to
have on other things.
I think that, right now, the distraction of
all things Russia and all things Trump/Russia
is distracting us from everything right now.
And I think it has been overplayed.
I mean, sounds like, and you can just imagine
this if you've watched the president,
He's sitting there with Comey and he's saying
'am I a target?'
And he says 'No mister President you're not
a target.'
'Tell the public then, why won't you tell
the public.'
You can see him brow-beating him and saying
'I want the public to know
because it's distracting from my agenda.'
And you do kind of wonder, if he really isn't
a target, why they wouldn't say that publicly.
And you can go into all the debate over whether
or not he was bringing undue pressure on him.
But the bottom line is, as Comey testified
today,
'Nobody told me not to investigate this stuff.'